Unidentified: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Dr. Steven Novella, who is a neurologist,
host and producer of the award winning podcast
The Skeptics Guide to the Universe, and also
lead author of the bestselling book By the
same name. I really appreciate your time.
It's great having you on today. Oh, thanks
for having me on. It's great to be here. You've
got the book and the podcast, really. These
are excellent sources for thinking about how
to evaluate why we believe the things we believe,
why others believe the things they believe,
how to engage with epistemology and critical
thinking, which is so important right now.
We could start this conversation, any of a
of a number of different ways. Can you talk
a little bit first generally about the approach
you find most useful when engaging with people
with different views to kind of create a baseline
from which we can have conversations about?
Do we believe things that are that are actually
true? What's the the general approach that
you propose? Yeah. Well, I think you're saying
that we need a baseline is a good approach.
The first step is always to establish some
common ground because if you don't have common
ground, pretty much you just fighting, right?
You're not talking, you're not engaging, you're
not going to make any progress. And you might
have to back up quite a ways to find out where
that common ground is. People make a lot of
assumptions. They don't even realize how many
different things go into their worldview,
how many assumptions are in there, and that
somebody else might not share those same assumptions.
So even things like How do we know what's
real or what evidence is reliable evidence,
etc.? Yeah. And once you establish that common
ground, you might, you might actually also
be surprised to find out that you have a lot
more common ground than you may think. That's
that's another common experience. And then
you can build slowly, carefully from there.
What are the goals? You know, how are we going
to figure out how to how to proceed here?
So I think there's a general picture. If you
just back up and find common ground, that's
a good way to begin. There are some pitfalls
sometimes in a lot of these conversations,
and I'm curious as to your thoughts about
how to navigate them. You know, there's these
concepts that are often bandied about like
Dunning Kruger, the idea that someone lacks
the ability or knowledge to understand that
they are not necessarily fully equipped to
have a certain conversation, which which comes
off as very insulting sometimes to say to
someone, in whatever words you want to use.
You know, Dunning Kruger may be limiting your
ability to engage meaningfully in this conversation.
The reality is sometimes people are kind of
in over their heads. So what are some more
productive ways, maybe to establish that someone
may just not have all of the information to
engage? Yeah. So, you know, I think the first
realization is that Dunning, Kruger and the
logical fallacy is critical thinking skills,
you know, media literacy. These things don't
apply to other people. They apply to you.
They apply to everyone. So if you're using,
you know, these critical thinking concepts
as a weapon in order to, you know, essentially
knock down or attack somebody else, you're
doing it wrong. You know, these mainly are
methods of policing your own thinking. And
so like Dunning Kruger, it doesn't mean that
some people are or they don't have the information
to evaluate their ignorance. It's everybody
does just to a different degree degree on
different topics. But unless you are at the
cutting edge of world expertize in a very
narrow topic, it applies to you. You don't
have enough information to really meaningfully
engage in how we know what we know about some
cutting edge technique, especially technical
topic. And so the other half of that is what
we call neuropsychological humility, right?
So that we all have to be humble and not saying
that you were dumb or you can't engage in
critical thinking or there are your cognitively
biased. It's we all are. We all need to confront
the way our brains work, the way our logic
tends to work. And you know, again, this gets
back to the to the common ground. Things like
we all need to work together to identify the
limitations in our knowledge, identify maybe
some of the biases that we're working with.
And then you can see if we can build from
there, too to some kind of common ground.
One of the things that, particularly during
the pandemic, often comes up, and I get a
lot of emails from people about this as well
as someone will say, Yeah, OK, so the CDC
and the show and my local doctor, they say
this. But did you see that like Gary NULL,
for example, is a name that people often email
me about, or they'll say or. Dr. John Campbell
on YouTube said this about ivermectin or whatever.
And. Sometimes I have the instinct, like when
callers say this stuff, to talk a little bit
about credentials like to say, Well, you know,
Dr. John Campbell, he has a doctorate in teaching
nursing. He's not a medical doctor, but at
the same time, I know that it's sort of an
appeal to authority. But I recognize it might
be relevant for someone to know whether we're
talking to a medical doctor or not, like it
seems relevant. But at the same time, it's
kind of just like going right to credentials.
What makes sense when it comes to something
like that? This is perhaps the trickiest thing
that we engage with because it's basically
dueling experts, right? And you can find an
expert to say whatever you want to support,
whatever position you want to have and you
feel like I'm listening to the experts. I've
got these experts over here and this phenomenon
has been weaponized. It's not like it's just
a random thing. There are people who are trying
to lead you down a path paved with these,
you know, cherry picked outlier expert opinions
or pseudo expert opinions. Or sometimes they're
not experts at all. And you know, you have
to be able to pick your way through that.
But again, if you're not an expert, how do
you do that? Again, you're not in a position
to evaluate which experts are legitimate.
So you need to have some basic algorithms
that you use some basic things, you know,
red flags or processes that you go through
to have at least a reasonable way of evaluating
people who have more expertize in an area
than you do. So I think there are probably
the biggest thing to do is to listen to a
consensus of many experts over an opinion
of one expert. No one expert is definitive.
Every any one person can be wrong could be
a complete outlier. But if you have, you know,
organizations that have some legitimacy like
they're not an ideological organization or,
like, you know, exist for for the purpose
of pushing an agenda. But they're like a university
or a professional organization, et cetera.
And they say, Yeah, we put together a panel
of experts and they recommend this. This is
how they like the American Medical Association,
for example, or, you know, any other like
medical professional organization who say,
Yeah, we reviewed the evidence and this this
is the standard of care that we think is the
case or, you know, the Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change. Yeah, we have 3000 climate
scientists got together and they go, Yeah,
this is 95 percent likely. What's going on?
You know, you can't put that up against one,
you know, one person as an expert in isolation
and say that they're equivalent. So I think
that's if you just did that, just sort out,
you know, with seemingly objective consensus
opinion among the greatest number of expert
possible, you're much more likely to be correct
than listening to one guy on YouTube, no matter
what his credentials seem to be when it comes
to medications. Would it be rather than what
one person says or a small study one doctor
did, saying the standard is sort of like the
randomized controlled trial and that that
would be what we look to. Yeah, well, that's
certainly not you're saying what is the standard
of evidence within that field? Right. So certainly
with with drugs and with a lot of medical
treatments, the standard is the randomized
trial, but it's more than that actually. It's
a systematic review of multiple randomized
controlled trials. Gotcha. One trial doesn't
really tell you anything because any one trial
could be a quirky result. It could be, you
know, you don't know what the pattern is.
Statistically speaking, you can't make many
firm conclusions based on one study. But once
you see what the pattern of evidence is among
many studies and that requires an expert systematic
review, which is a great way, by the way,
to get a good quick idea of what is the consensus
of opinion about this medical topic is look
at some high quality, systematic reviews.
You know, then that tells you what's likely
to be the case, because then you're seeing
a pattern of evidence, not just one piece
of evidence right now. What set of false,
factually false beliefs? I'm not using the
term conspiracy theory because sometimes it's
not really a conspiracy theory. It's just
people believe something that's not true.
What's the most concerning or to you or that
you believe is most damaging to us in society
right now? Well, I mean, certainly anti-vaccine
attitudes are incredibly harmful, especially
in the middle of a pandemic. I mean, it's
definitely slowing down and impairing our
ability to tamp down this pandemic and increasing
the odds that new variants are going to emerge
and prolong the pandemic. So that's definitely,
you know, in the short term, that's probably
the biggest thing. Long term, I have to say
climate change, you know, we need to be the
conversation we need to be having is how best
to avoid the worst case scenarios of climate
change and how to mitigate the the expensive
and very disruptive effects that are that
are already happening and are and we know
we're going to be getting worse rather than
the endless discussion of is it happening
or, you know, trying to do whatever we can
to avoid, you know, reducing fossil fuel company
profits, which is, I think, what most of the
you know, the pushback is really all about.
We sort of get stuck spinning our wheels.
And again, that's better on purpose. That's
by design. You know it literally. There are
paid PR experts who spread fear, uncertainty
and doubt to delay things as much as possible.
It's just so easy for that to happen because,
you know, it's just easy to generate. The
sort of false skepticism is, you know, what
I call science denial in order to prolong
the discussion in this preliminary phase of
is it happening? Is there anything we can
do about it? And then, of course, to sort
of nit pick and shoot down any proposed solutions
rather than engage meaningfully with what
is the best solutions to this problem? What
will minimize any short term negative economic
impact? What's going to have the greatest
chance of succeeding long term, etc. And there's
lots of great proposals on the table and it's
happening. It's just we just need to accelerate
it so that we can again avoid risking some
tipping points or the worst outcome. So in
the long run for humanity, I think that's
the biggest issue that we're facing. There
are people who sometimes categorize false
beliefs with a very fine line between them,
the sort of the ones that are materially damaging,
like you point out climate science denial,
preventing us from actually putting in place
some real infrastructure here. To deal with
this, or anti-vax is literally it prolonging
a a pandemic? And then they'll say, OK, and
then there's a fine line. And on the other
side, there's stuff that's basically benign,
like flat Earth, for example. Yeah, I've spoken
to psychologists who specialize in paranoid
and conspiracies, beliefs and different people
who say it's not really that fine of a line
because often something seemingly benign like
flat-Earth belief is associated with people
with antisemitic conspiracy theories that
they believe or there's overlap with the anti-vax
movement or whatever. Can you give us your
sense of whether there really are these two
categories, or whether it's much more of a
gray area? Oh, there's there aren't two categories.
It's all just a continuum of one thing. OK?
There's there's certainly more or less direct
harm or demonstrable harm from certain belief
systems, like if you believe that modern medicine
is a conspiracy, you know, and you should
treat all things with with prayer or drinking
your own urine or whatever, something bizarre
like that would help people actually believe,
by the way, then yeah, that's sort of it could
easily easily see how immediately harmful
that can be. There's the other beliefs like
flat earther, for example, you may or belief
in ghosts is when we are, well, who cares
if people believe in ghosts? It's the harm
is not as obvious, but it's still there. You
may need to dig a little bit to see what the
tangible physical harm is, but there's also
epistemological harm, right when people believe
in magic. When they don't understand the basics
of how science is working, when they believe
it's all a conspiracy, you are setting them
up for the harmful conspiracy to come, the
more immediate, obviously harmful thing. So
and sometimes it's not that long a trip there.
So if you believe in magic, you believe in
astrology or whatever, then you may or you're
much more likely to be hoodwinked by, let's
say, a psychic who we know there are fraudulent
psychics out there who steal millions of dollars
from people. I mean, that's not harmless.
So, you know, the harm may be a little bit
more secondary and harder to quantify, but
it's there. And when you do this, you know,
for a living for a long time, you see you
see the harm, you know, even if it's a little
bit downstream. There's tremendous harm from
believing in magic. It makes you incredibly
vulnerable. It is not isolated. And so, you
know, we should not think of these things
as benign at all. Do we all have some of these
beliefs, like, for example, I think of myself
as someone who follows science and I ask myself,
why do I believe this or that? But just like
to pick something random? Oftentimes, when
I'm traveling somewhere new and eating some
food I've not had, I'll mention I really hope
this doesn't make me sick. And I think on
some level, I think that by mentioning it,
I'm kind of like putting it out, and it's
like less likely that a weird new food in
some new country. I don't really believe that.
I know that the thing I say doesn't actually
make a difference, but it's sort of like one
of these. It's a false belief. It doesn't
really have an impact on whether a food will
make me sick. Do we all have some of these
things, do you think? Oh, sure. So, you know,
no one is intellectually pristine, right?
So, you know, humans are predisposed to superstitious
thinking like what you're saying. And sometimes,
you know, we engage in that for fun or for
comfort or for because of tradition or ritual.
But we know intellectually like, yes, there's
no magic here. This is not actually true.
I cannot ward off food poisoning by saying,
I hope this isn't poisonous, but you still
do it. That's I mean, that's I think is benign.
If you know, intellectually, this is not true.
And it's just part of just human behavior.
Although, you know, some people like to police
that within themselves as well just because
they think it could help keep their keep their
critical thinking skills focused, which is
fine as well, but also in terms of what we
actually believe. No one's, you know, belief
system is or what they hold to be true is
perfect, either. It's just impossible to get
to that point. But yes, I purged myself of
all inaccurate conclusions and false beliefs
and everything I believe is 100 percent accurate,
true and precise. That's that's an aspirational
goal that we will never get to. The real difference
between people are those who engage in metacognition
and those who don't. What's metacognition
especially thinking about thinking it's turning
a analytical eye toward your own thinking
processes and trying to understand how you
come to conclusions, how you come to believe
things examining, improving, tweaking that
process, being open to changing your beliefs
based upon evidence and logic, et cetera,
and those people who don't really actively
engage in metacognition, they sort of go with
their psychological process level. They're
just sort of following the current, you know,
the mental current to whatever conclusion
it brings them to and not examining the process.
So you're never going to be somebody who's
whose beliefs are pristinely perfect, but
you can be somebody who examines everything
they believe in is willing to change their
mind. And so again, we say it's a journey,
it's a process. If you live your life as somebody
who can get less and less wrong, you know,
over time, that's the best you can do. But
it's better than remaining in a position where
you're not even examining your beliefs and
you're just going with with whatever your
your age is telling you to believe that that
makes a lot of sense. Last thing, I want to
talk about changing other people's minds.
There are many folks I've spoken to who say
at the wholesale, look at a societal level.
When we see rapid changing of minds, it's
often coming at the hands of authoritarianism,
dictatorship, the Chinese Cultural Revolution,
et cetera. If we think more at the retail
level of individuals, it's building relationships
and often applying a sort of Socratic type
method of questioning to get other people
to say, Hey, maybe I'm not as solidly grounded
in this belief as I thought I was. Do you
agree that that is a good method, and it seems
like it takes a very long time to change minds?
Well, yeah, so that it depends on contexts
and people ask us this question all the time
and say, Well, what's your relationship? What
are your goals? What's your investment if
you're playing the long game? Right, this
is somebody that you have a long term relationship
with, et cetera. Or, you know, even if on
a wholesale level where you're trying to influence
culture. Organizations or institutions, you
can you have to play the long game. You know,
you can't just browbeat somebody with a belief
and expect them to change their mind. It's
far better to just give them critical thinking
skills, establish a little baseline of scientific
literacy, some media savvy, and let them come
to that conclusion by themselves. Sometimes
a good way to do this is again, find common
ground. I like to say you just find something
that someone is skeptical about and ask them
why they're skeptical about that. You don't.
So you're saying you don't believe in ancient
astronauts who would ever pick something,
find something they don't believe in. Say,
Why don't you believe in that white? And then
they will usually, you know, give a pretty
skeptical reason for why that there's no evidence
it doesn't make any sense or whatever, is
it? That's right. And then you just engage
them, engage their skepticism and try to to
nurture that, grow that generalize those skills.
And once they see the trait, people believed
this and that was wrong. And how could that?
How does that work? And they, you know, they
begin to generalize their skepticism and then
eventually they'll turn it more inward. And
hopefully, you know, more and more things
will fall that, you know, to really hard core
skeptics, like all belief falls that eventually
everything gets subjected to the skeptical,
the skeptical eye. So that's the goal. But
that is absolutely the long game. That's years.
You know, it's a process you end. And even
for seasoned skeptics, we still will fall
prey to emotional beliefs or misinformation
or not realize that we're being ideological
when we think we're being. When we think we're
being logical, it's hard. It's not. It's not
easy that it's a complicated world and there's
a lot of misinformation out there, and our
brains are really flawed at doing this, whereas
only semi rational creatures. So at best,
it's a process. But you know, if you engage
in it, either personally or with other people
trying to get them to be more skeptical. It's
a lifelong process. That's interesting. I
mean, thinking out loud about an issue that
we're dealing with right now, which is people
blaming Joe Biden for a lot of things that
either happened before he was president or
that are happening in other countries, rather
than the approach of, well, what did he do
to cause that? I wonder if there would be
something to saying, Hey, listen, do you blame
Joe Biden for the challenger disaster? And
most people would probably say, Well, no,
I don't, and maybe there's an opportunity
to say, Well, why not? And they might give
some reasons, which then would also apply
to some of the areas that they're blaming
him today. Yeah, that's that's a good approach.
I like to take the approach with myself, you
know, for myself, but also to other people.
It's like, imagine if there were a president
of your party president right now and this
were happening. What would you say? Just do
the thought experiment, right? If you just
say, Oh yeah, we totally blame them for everything,
just as much as anything, would you really
think about it? Really put yourself in that
position and just say, you know, if you had
to do that and that's sort of the devil's
advocate approach, like if you had to defend
the other position, what would you say? A
great, always a great thought experiment.
It gets people engaging with the other side
and then they and then, you know, pretty soon,
like, yeah, you know, just getting them to
think that way makes them think that way.
That's psychologists have demonstrated that
frequently. Just if you tell people to take
it, to just pretend they have a position,
they actually move towards that position.
If you tell people, just pretend you're thinking
skeptically here for a minute and then do
that as an exercise that actually gets them
thinking more skeptically, that's super interesting
that that's a that's a very good idea. We've
been speaking with Dr. Steven Novella, who
is the host and producer of the award winning
podcast The Skeptics Guide to the Universe
and lead author of the book by the same name.
Such a pleasure having you on. I really appreciate
it. A lot of fun. Thanks for having me.